okay
let's do it
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to
your absolutely
favorite podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's up y'all
cleveland griffin is back
um
i'm at home doing the intro but i did
the podcast on the road my guest today
is mr leonard robinson uh live from a
hotel room the quality is a little
shabby on the video but we got good
audio and i just i'm having it up on
youtube just so i know people that like
to see it like that but we you know we
talk about his career
we talk we go into detail about the
ghostbusters movie but welcome back to
so we really get into it so i hope you
enjoy
[Music]
you know what i mean
that's how we do it here
that's how we do it here onboard from a
girlfriend um so anyways like i said
today's guest is mr leonard robinson
um live from my hotel in arizona this
past weekend
um a little late with the podcast one
day a little bit late just because i had
to film i mean i'm in this little
independent movie and so i had to film
so i had a flu fly back on monday and
then go right to set it just was a whole
thing but here is the podcast and i hope
you enjoy
what do you want to eat tonight y'all
you want uh some home cooked favorites
but you don't feel like going to the
store
i got it for you it's doordash get 25
off at zero delivery fees on your first
order of 15 or more when you download
the doordash app and enter code griffin
ritual multivitamins are delivered to
your door every month with key
ingredients your body needs ritual is
offering my listeners 10 off during your
first three months visit ritual.com
griffin to start your ritual today
wait oh wait you see what i'm saying
wait am i rolling in yeah am i rolling
in to be the intro or am i going to
become lights up but you have it on the
mic it's on yeah i see my no
that's something else
that's a separate recording on here it's
moving okay yeah as long as it's on all
right all right we're good griffin
i know i mean you're focused
perfect tommy okay
if you're home alone
you're ripping with griffin
okay that'll be the intro for the show
yeah
all right everybody uh welcome back to
riffing with griffin this is on the on
the road edition um i was at uh arizona
stand up live and leonard robinson came
with me today's guest my longtime friend
long long longtime friend comedian actor
leonard robinson hey thanks for having
me yeah but anyways yes we here at
phoenix
those that's being weird we're just
talking like we normally do so we're in
phoenix because your family's here
you're there for food yeah i got my
family out here anytime i come out to
visit my family i try to do some
stand-up and because i got you know a
bunch of clubs out here so but wait was
you originally from connecticut though
right yes i grew up for the most part in
connecticut the parents just got older
and they moved out to a hot place they
move out to
it was a good idea when they were mobile
but then when you get you know when you
get extra old and slow it's just like
yeah you're like an ant underneath the
you're like an underneath the magnifying
glass i know and then it's like it's the
weather and it's also a good cost of
living here as opposed to like the east
coast or even los angeles but
but um leonard is on a series regular on
the great show on hbo insecure with issa
rae
um
yeah man it's a good it's a good show i
appreciate you watching things yeah yeah
well but i was watching the show even
before you were on the show so that was
just like a bonus
yeah leonard and i are part of a crew
it's called the worst crew ever
it's
w-c-e
in the house that's me leonard robinson
craig robinson
and malcolm barrett
uh we
are
really good friends with quotes yeah
but i think i think it was more so like
the worst crew ever is that you know
because like hollywood or all kinds of
places you know people got clicks like
people have clicks and music you know
like cash money records or something
like that like we could be a power we
could
a powerful crew
i don't know what it is
okay we had to pinpoint whose fault is
it who's who like if we had to lay out
some blame definitely craig's
hands down
yeah cause craig roberts is he's
obviously the most famous of us yeah i
mean look if it's voltron you know what
i mean like he's the black the black cat
the black cat's got to form voltron
can you imagine if every you know the
voltron it was just like the green yeah
it was just the arms the arms on one leg
people like shut the [ __ ] will you shut
your yeah yeah right leg ass up right
yeah
yeah we need uh we need yeah it was
craig's fault we just gonna put it on
him craig
but i've been on like
yeah but you know what it's not for lack
of effort because
like you went out for a series regular
for one of craig's shows yeah i actually
was i did a guest star on whatever the
ghost one
and then that one got cancelled
but you know you can't put too much
pressure on people in these positions
you know when people blow up and people
rise up and fall you know sometimes
people
you know project all the perceived power
and influence people that you know have
it's just like you know
i mean even on a lower level you know
when you got past the comedy store i'm
sure like people were out hey hey how do
i get how do i get past she's like
this just happened for me like i don't
know what you can't stand when people
skip steps like that anyway that whole
skip-to-step process like hey man who
books that like you know what i'm not
your agent
i'm not your agent right but but then
like you know then we got like malcolm
but you know what at least everybody's
doing their thing i think that's what's
good about it everybody did we all of
them been in comedy all have been in
television in movies i mean you got
somebody like malcolm from what i
you know from what i know about malcolm
he's booked a pilot like every year he's
ever
been a professional actor
they don't always you know well they
never go but he's got a couple he's got
a couple of hit but you know they don't
oh that's true because i'm talking about
like but i'm thinking of sitcoms but
like yeah cause he was on timeless yeah
then he was on thomas and he was on
yeah yeah yeah yeah he's always on
something he's always like if you saw
him you'd be like oh that guy yeah you
know he's been on the podcast before too
man when i came to l.a immediately got
on wildin out on mtv which was like you
know pretty popular uh for a time
and then you know go through different
phases then you move into something else
you move you know but your personality i
it always if you knowing you now
i would never think you were on wild out
yeah you know what i mean like i know i
don't i still
i still don't believe it sometimes when
i gotta see footage
i need to see well it's yeah the footage
is actually the show that was taped
i know but i said you can buy it or rent
it today but i was never one i never was
a while and now person
um what's weird is i wasn't i was just
doing in i have weird things about me
that um
that i guess people could think of are
weird because i just get into stuff
without a purpose if that if that makes
any sense like or the purpose is for
something else so i got into improv
because i thought it was it would make
me just a regular a better actor in
general
so that's how i started taking improv
classes like i didn't have a goal to be
an improv guy and perform in improv
shows and theaters as a matter of fact
you know we laugh all the time about
you know our love and hate relationship
with improv yeah yeah and i'm a member
of the groundlings uh
shows all the time and i do shows there
all the time i do i'm there weekly doing
improv yeah and then i always think but
to me to me
improv to me is a tool to be a better
actor or company so that's how i fell
into it i just wanted to be a better
actor and then i you know i started
doing stand-up actually lewis black
taught me
how to do stand-up at a theater festival
i met him in williamstown massachusetts
at a theater festival oh [ __ ] and he was
like i'll just do a stand-up workshop
which was basically
was basically him hosting an open mic
and then he would just sit in the end
sit in the back after you were done be
like that's not funny
oh man that's never going to be funny
that sounds terrible yeah and every now
and then be like why would you think
that was funny
also he was you know what he was trying
to do he was trying to do a culling of
the of the state of the stand-up
business he was trying to be like oh you
think you could be funny no you're not
and then hopefully those people will
never do it again and the ones that
stick through are the ones that's going
to make it i tell you man people people
take like these classes and whatever and
i just think like that was the best
class i ever had which was really kind
of not a class you just like do it and i
got some tapes that you can watch some
specials from comedians that i love go
go to your room and watch them and then
go write stuff and come back and we'll
do it again and and after like four
weeks then we did a showcase for the
whole
theater company
in a theater that my first now that i
think about oh [ __ ] we were talking
about theaters today
my first experience doing stand-up was
in a theater oh wow with like maybe 500
people or something in there damn all
the maybe it's 300 um
i could be exaggerating
it turns out you were at a coffee shop
and it was like 32 people in there no
but it was one of the theaters i don't i
can't remember how many people but i saw
the way i got into it i saw the workshop
before i did it and all these people
were funny
he made all these people but he coached
them into being funny really all of them
were funny and i was like this is crazy
because i've talked to these people
nobody has made me laugh ever so was it
like a class no like i said it was like
an open mic you just did you just did
maybe like four or five of them and then
he's like we're going to do a show and
everybody gets you know now granted you
only had to do like three minutes
but he found a way to pull all that
stuff out because i took a class like a
like like i took a comedy class i
thought ucla extension oh how was that
yeah it was crazy it was it was taught
by sandy shore oh well that was that
that was probably good right you would
think
you know what i mean but i always
recommend i actually recommend people
taking a class at least once
when if you're first starting and you
want and you want to like because it's a
really comfortable
environment a safe environment you know
that you that you could like work on
these things with like-minded
individuals who are probably on your
same level and then you build up some
confidence over like whatever eight ten
weeks and then you go and then you go
out into the uh the world and like try
to do it so you know that's what what it
was for me that's true and i don't know
i'm not hating on comedy classes i mean
these are this one neither am i but i
said i don't think you should stay in
them oh no but i just know that a lot of
stand-ups that i that i met coming up
just just did it which which back you
know which more reinforces what you're
talking about like take a class
sometimes because it's like how do you
just go out and do it like
you you read all these stories like
sarah silverman started at 13 like
chappelle started at 13. i'm like how
how
you met my nephew today he's 13. i'm
like no way he's gonna make it as a
stand-up by the way
i'm so glad blender brought up his name
oh man now i got to get the water yeah
get the water oh you know what there's
there's other waters in that okay okay
by the water coming yeah so
yesterday i saw spiderman which i will
review on next week's episode
and so i was gonna go see it again
and landon was like well i'm gonna bring
my nephew and he goes look us at the
times and goes why don't we go see
ghostbusters it was the earliest time he
was let's go see ghostbusters and he
brings his nephew and i'm like i wonder
why we're seeing ghostbusters
you know and i actually i didn't want to
see it because we're nostalgic yeah
ghostbusters is from our our era really
it's cause we're old and we're just like
hey you don't sound like a good idea and
they already ruined it with the like the
all-female one anyway so i was like i
wonder if they're gonna redeem
themselves with this one you know and
i'm like all right let's go you know
because if you don't have the main guys
it's like what are you doing it's just a
rehash of okay so
paul rudd and we go see ghostbusters and
it is
terrible well
this is where i want to disagree yeah i
don't think he was terrible
i think it's who are you doing this for
i think who's this for right now is that
i think it's in case a producer want to
hire you are you talking to somebody i
got two things to say i think it's a
fine film
it's fine it's perfectly fine what part
of it was fine it's fine there's a lot
of fun look that kid that podcast kid in
the movie he was funny god i was
cracking me up that kid was good man and
just that character alone i was like
you've never seen a character like that
in the movie can we could we i'm going
to do i was great i was going to do this
by myself but also i was a little high i
took a wee
nephew and i was like
that explains a lot this is all right
now normally what i do on my podcast is
i pick a movie like that like one time i
watched fast and furious nine on a plane
and it was so crazy that when i got home
i did my podcast what i did was i
recapped the whole movie oh okay you
know now i usually since we just saw
ghostbusters so this is the spoiler
alert for anybody that wants to
alert but a movie that's been out for
almost a year now uh no it's only been
out like
five months oh well that's how bad it
must be then because nobody knows it was
out or no
nobody was in this theater just came no
it didn't just come out it's been out i
was like oh ghostbusters yeah yeah i i'm
surprised it was still in the theaters
it's been out for five months yeah it's
been out a while dude it's been a while
i think i think it's even worse yeah i
feel even worse for making that big
yeah so we took your
so spider-man is out and it was
fantastic one of the best movies i've
seen in a long time your nephew wanted
to see spider-man and we took him to see
ghostbusters
what's up y'all
you trying to look for something to eat
tonight um i suggest you get doordash
man
you can get dinner household essentials
everything on the grocery store list you
can get it all delivered with doordash
ever pull up into a driveway after a
trip to the grocery store only to
realize you forgot one key item
or something an ingredient for dinner
well now you have options you can use
door draft drawer dash to get groceries
to get a backup meal get stuff from your
favorite local restaurant delivered
right from the door dash app it's time
to get back out there
but if you're not quite ready for a
full-blown adventure
explore the world from the comfort of
your own home with doordash
this past year taught us to savor every
moment together spend less time prepping
food and more time eating and spending
time with your loved ones with the help
of doordash what i love about doordash
is you get what you want to eat they got
all the local restaurants what i
realized there's more restaurants on
there than you even realize like i have
a lot of little favorites in my area and
they're all right there i use it they
come it's great i've used it for
groceries when i need some stuff last
minute or even if i just don't feel like
going any place i use door jash if
you're craving late at night sometimes
rachel and i want some donuts i know we
shouldn't do it but we do it we use
doordash the donuts come right away with
over 300 000 partners you can support
your neighborhood go-to places like we
do papa's chipotle cheesecake factory
whatever it is for a limited time our
listeners get 25 off and zero delivery
fees on their first order of 15 or more
when you download the door dash app and
enter code griffin that's 25 off up to
10 value and zero delivery fees on your
first order when you download the
doordash app in the app store and enter
code griffin that's g-r-i-f-f
don't forget that's code griffin for 25
off your first order with doordash
subject to change terms apply
travesty so
let's just go over these more
is worse now that i know
out for five months a minute i don't
know if it's been out for five months
but it's been out for months oh my god i
gotta look that up yeah you gotta look
it up that's
ghostbusters been out a while but just
come on man this movie was bad all right
you know so the movie the movie opens up
with just family yeah a girl
a lady she's she's a mom deadbeat sort
of mom yeah the mom the mom the mom had
me worried i was like yeah i was like
but is she an alcoholic brian pay the
rent or whatever she ain't paying her
bills but because she's got a smile on
her face i'm supposed to like but this
is one of those tropes they use where
they make the parents dumb and the kids
smart
so like so then you have this smart
little girl yeah who's a scientist and
she's an introvert super genius rewiring
in the apartment yeah she's like you
know and she's got a witty banter with
the mom and then you got the sort of
teenage boy who's like you know
obviously the rebel but he's got like
this sort of like relationship with the
mom too where everybody's got like it's
all gilmore girls sort of like you know
you know
right banter banter
badger banter
banter
so that's what was going on and then you
find out that her father
oh well actually the movie opens up with
like the movie opens up with a sort of
action scene you never see the guy's
face and he's trying to escape a ghost
uh he's trapped a ghost and then this
person is trying to you know obviously
it's like a ghostbuster person because
he's got ghostbusters uh
machinery and then like you know it's a
big car chase with a ghost chasing him
and he gets back to his like farm in
this sort of ghost house and then like
he's trying to do a thing and it doesn't
work he's trying to trap the ghost in
his yard
the electricity blows out so now he's
sitting in his chair and he hides the uh
the trap the trap and then he gets
killed and then he gets which is weird
because i'm like yeah well first of all
who killed them yeah well
why would the ghost kill him where why
would it goes kept they looking for this
thing right they're looking for the
thing right and so you wait i'm supposed
to believe that a ghost can't find a
secret trap door that's what i'm saying
it's a ghost the ghost is flying through
so that's just some of the logical
problems so
for some reason the ghost can't find
this trap door ghost in the living room
that's all we know for the for sure
about ghosts is they go through walls
they go through walls
okay so these guys we got ghosts that
don't go through walls this for some
reason this ghost can't find this thing
and they all they had to do was show
like some ruins or something like to
make us see that oh this is like a
secret compartment that ghost can't get
into like you know it's like like if it
was a box made of lead that superman
can't see oh yeah that's a good point
yeah give us some kind of thing there
was nothing like that yeah it's not yeah
it's not a secret talisman in it
nothing a little
there's no like salt
all right so then so there's a big
action sequence then you cut to we meet
the the family of three and then she's
getting kicked out but she finds out
that her father died
and her father's being had been a
deadbeat dad for years
he left them uh you know out of out of
his life
you know and then but then you come to
find out that it's spanx spengel
spengman whatever
egon from the ghostbust the original
ghostbusters played by harold ramis who
passed away in 2014. but we going to get
to that
but then they got to go out to see this
farm this dirt farm they show up oh well
when she gets kicked out she you you
find out that she can't pay the rent
yeah she's not gonna pay the rent you're
not gonna be able to pay the rent so
they're going down a summer trip and
turns out they're gonna be there forever
forever to some
from a it's a town that i think has
had that had one farm yeah four
buildings and a
and yet it seems like there's ten
thousand people there right it doesn't
seem like it's not but you never see
them
yeah okay but wait let's get to
so they get to this farm and when they
get to the farm
we meet one of the old cast of the
ghostbusters it was the late the the
secretary from the original ghostbusters
she shows up and i was in the theater
like and we're in there with eight
people and i felt to myself this is one
of those moments that we're supposed to
be like
and we didn't nobody did anything so it
was kind of weird all right so then
she's explaining the story that the
father and so the mom clearly has like
contempt for her dad she's upset that
her dad was never in her life okay and
then of course this little genius girl
now this is what gets me stuff starts to
happen yeah
you know like stuff is moving
like she playing a chess game with a
ghost yeah and she don't say nothing
about it right yeah like you know she
don't even react one thing we know about
kids
they're gonna freak out over a ghost
instead she's kind of like oh well hold
on a minute yeah like the chess board
falls over and she puts it back together
and who thinks that fast oh that was
weird i should set up an experiment i
should set up another game and i know
the exact experiment that i need to do
right now to communicate with a ghost
that i think that i don't believe in
that i don't know is there but here's
the thing the first time
when she moved the chess piece and she
leaves and comes back and then there's
another the other side moved i thought
well then she made me think oh this is
weird maybe my brother
but when she does it again and it
actually moves by itself no reaction
like literally no reaction yeah well um
well you know what these choices the
acting choices i didn't understand
there's no motivation in this
there was a line in the movie where she
said something about like i don't
experie experience emotions like other
people like i'm you know i am dying
inside like i'm mad inside and that made
me think it's like are they trying to
say that this character's on the
spectrum or something like that oh was
that a no i don't know but yeah nobody
got freaked out about ghosts not even
not one way or the other
we were like wait let's go down to the
ghost yeah they were like oh there's
none of ghosts okay so she finds this so
she finds the the trap door she figures
out there's some sort of like you know
she's smart so she pulls out this
ghostbusters trap she doesn't know what
it is okay so all right anyway cut to
before that she has to go to school now
yeah everybody's got to go back
everybody got to go back to school she's
in this new town all of a sudden
she's in this town and by the way
most diverse oklahoma town i've ever
seen in my life there's a muslim girl in
the in this oklahoma town black family a
black family who's four generations in
this town
and the and the sheriff of this town in
oklahoma
is black yeah
and his daughter was very like obviously
the mom's white but they didn't even
imply that but clearly the mom was white
you know what i mean
it was like it was it was i was thinking
to myself like
why make it in oklahoma then like why
make it in oklahoma if you want to be
like let's have diversity i didn't
understand why they had the little girl
dressed in the muslim gear i also didn't
need to see that many people i just
i was like okay
i could have done with a town of four
people yeah i just it was so ridiculous
you know and then and then the main the
funniest kid in the movie play i don't
know what the kid's name is but his
character he was called podcast because
he was doing the podcast he was funny he
was great he was the funniest thing in
the movie and paul rudd i thought he was
just kind of like
pedestrianly going through this thing
like all right i guess i got to do this
hey paul rudd's in a in a place in this
in his own in his career where he
probably does 10 movies a year like he's
like i'm i'm in i'm out and it's just
it's just they're just rolling out paul
rudd's i know so he's so he's a
seismologist that's the summer school
teacher
and i did think it was funny that he
comes in as a summer school teacher and
he goes i don't want to be here you
don't want to be here and he plays them
cujo
that made me laugh that was a good
running joke yeah and then chuck chucky
did child's play he's playing to these
kids so the little girl roams into the
office as chucky oh that's true
sorry black listen to this podcast
remember the movie child's play yeah
with a character called chucky in it so
the little girl goes into this the
teacher's office and then she realizes
oh she sees all his maps and stuff and
then they start having a sciency talk
which was crazy and then she he also
realizes that later they bring the
the stuff that they found and then he
goes hey that's a real
that's a real ghostbusters thing yeah
people know too much stuff already like
right away indeed they don't explain how
they know these things and they also
made it seem like this big huge event
happened in 84 yeah where new york was
overrun by monsters
and then they want to act like 20 years
later people didn't believe it was real
right like like the holocaust deniers or
something you know what i mean it didn't
happen like it didn't happen and that
was just 20 years that's fresh that's
real fresh fresh you know what i'm
saying so so they're like so then he
sees the ghostbuster thing and it's like
obviously there's like he goes oh is
that a replica you know because he's
like the ghostbuster aficionado and he's
like and she's like no then he realized
it's a real ghostbuster trap with a
ghost in it
and they make the choice
let's open this let's open it let's open
this thing that we don't know how to use
it may contain a ghost yeah so he knows
that what it is and what happened in 84
and they decide you know what let's open
it and here's the thing that got me so
they opened this ghostbuster trap a
demon comes out of the trap and flies
off
blast car window yeah
but also first of all it terrified him
and
ran and the thing ran away but then they
jumped up and cheered it was like wait a
minute yeah they were like oh wow but my
thing was like you just let loose a
demon
and no one had a reaction it was he just
was like oops we got to get out of here
yeah he won't get like a a parking
ticket or something it just was like it
didn't make any sense to me and then
that's how the rest of the movie played
out okay so then you know the the the
ghost stuff starts to happen and nobody
cares you know like the these kids the
the the sun is on a mountain that's like
a demon mountain you know and they're
looking down this well
and
clearly there's a demon in the well
though demons like
and then later they decide i know what
we should do
we should go down and check down there
and when the demon scared the kids they
cheered again
as well like everyone's like ooh that
was crazy right high five something
happened in this small town so then they
were like and then they were having like
sort of like parallel story lines to the
original ghostbusters where you had the
key master and the other thing and they
had to like mate to bring the
the the main goats it was the same
villain from the first one zul whatever
it is
yeah they had the same villain and then
like this person's gonna come back again
and then like okay here's another one so
they
they they the boy all of a sudden is
also a super mechanic because he fixes
this
40 year old car dusty cadillac dustin
cadillac he found with no money no money
just i don't even see tools
i just need tools and money nothing and
he's like come on he's like you know he
had the the the hood open that he just
closes the hood he gets in the car and
then he's like but then they tried to
imply that the ghost helped yes so
because they they saw that the electric
thing kind of fixed itself he starts the
car he starts driving off so now oh the
little girl and the podcast guy they run
into a real ghost and she's got like
this you know the the the ghostbusters
gun and they're trying to count back the
proton pack and they're trying to
capture this ghost then they run into
the brother who just happens to be
driving by i don't know where they were
i don't know why they were at a factory
at first they were at the yeah the
abandoned factory and then they were
walking back back on the road but nobody
had to abandon factories where they ran
into a ghost and then he you know on
that on that joyride ends up on the road
but but to your point it's like it makes
it seem like it's springfield where
you're just like i can't tell where
anybody is on the map
where is any how far away are we
so they get into a ghost chase all this
happening in the backyard yeah so they
chasing this ghost now and she's like
using the the proton pack and destroying
the town and they're zipping around on
this dude in the car and they capture
the ghost and then they get arrested you
know so now she's in jail
all right so now she's also starting to
figure out that her grandfather
was he he he he was doing something
right hey
if i'm gonna say anything was bad about
movies the worst part about the movie is
what happens in this scene where she has
to make the one phone she makes one
phone call and she decides to call
dan aykroyd's character who was like one
of the ghostbusters to say hey
and they she goes i'm in jail yeah and
they proceeded to have
the
a three to five minute exposition call
about
you know what happened what's been
happening for the last 20 years they got
us caught up with just little girls in
jail and he just talks like oh yeah i
get random calls from little girls all
the time and i tell my life story
i just it was like it was a kind of
choice where i go why
yeah that one that one feel like i mean
that that scene right there i don't know
i mean we're talking like we've written
movies um
no we watch a lot of movies
and the ones that we like these are the
reasons why we like it that's true
like i don't have to like know how to
play basketball to appreciate yeah when
it's good but it's good you still know
what it's bad yeah i still know what
it's bad this this movie was three for
20.
[Laughter]
no rebounds six files right so it just
felt like something that they that they
put in after they made the movie they
already did a cut and this is like one
of those reshoot scenes or something's
like well you know shouldn't we
i know and they're just like all right
well let's do it with a phone call then
because we're not going to pay for a
whole then they fixed this sat and ship
you off to oklahoma to shoot this so
then they figure obviously they figure
out what's going on they think they they
think of the kids they scooby-doo this
thing
you know what i mean they scooby this
thing to death and they figure out
what's going on the love interest of the
boy who's this black girl they you know
she's she's brought into the fold and
now they got the ghostbusters outfits on
and then
and they immediately jump right into
like yeah i mean all of a sudden this
movie deserved a training montage
something you know like one of those
black belt theater where you like when
you go like this
you see them hitting the glasses
some music starts playing i mean you see
people reading and getting up to speed
all of a sudden she you know and she
also can fix this like
nuclear-powered thing
the proton pack is just laying around
all right so then like of course there's
a big chase there's a big like fight
they figure out that the grandfather
made this farm to be a big ghost trap so
they figure out how to fix that and they
lure the the main ghost back and it's
just a whole thing
you know and then and then they show the
ghost of harold ramos yeah and then
which original ghostbusters come out
help save the day
right and they show up and it was so
like they didn't really want to be there
and you know in a in a little bit of a
a little uh plot hole is the the when
they finally capture the all the ghosts
they set up that the members said that
the backyard is filled with ghost traps
yeah yeah yeah yeah and it got all this
power
and it lit up everything well when all
the ghost traps went
it should not only get gozer and the
demons but it should also suck hale
ramus into it yeah yeah they didn't and
they didn't he's just standing and and
then it ends with the with the with the
daughter hugging her dad finally getting
that resolution right right i actually
hugged him i was like i thought you
couldn't touch a ghost yeah but he was a
special kind of ghost
so she gets to hug him and then even on
the screen they said for harold but it
was a long
scene
of an actual dead guy yeah like wait it
made me feel uncomfortable yeah it got
to a point because i even had to google
in the theater i was like i think he's
dead you know and he did he died in
2014.
so i don't know how they did this like
found footage or stills and then he just
brought a lot a lot of computing went on
to do that to it was a lot but repeat
that and they had aged them too
it was just a lot so i don't know guys i
mean just i i did not enjoy that movie
at all so if you're uh wherever you're
at if uh if something is a new release
or there's
ghostbusters just know go see the new
release those monsters been out i don't
know i don't know why we got into that
but we did uh but you know it's so
embarrassing i know and then this poor
nephew was like why didn't we see ghosts
why didn't we see spiderman
i don't know what's wrong with me
then we had a whole discussion about
like why we didn't go see spider-man he
threw me under the bus man it seemed
like it was my fault
well last night when we were getting
ready to leave after the club was like
you know we could see go we both we both
i was like all right i'll see
ghostbusters but i was cause i already
seen spider-man but i said cause lewis
wanted to go i said i'll go see
spider-man again and you didn't even you
were like you know yeah i just thought
you were joking at that time oh my god
his poor nephew man i don't know you
know that that just was crazy but as a
family that was a failed moment man i
could i could have saved the day and
hell he has a failed moment
but getting back to it to the other
stuff uh
tell me about
this season of insecure because it sucks
because you became a serious regular and
they ended the show yeah
i mean look you get it when you get it
but uh i know i mean look i was a fan of
the of the web series and i thought
anissa ray so i mean i was i didn't know
she had a web series oh man that's how
that's the whole show though you know um
misadventures of awkward black girl um
is is basically is the television
i didn't realize it was like it was like
based off the okay okay yeah i knew she
was on the web i knew she did that stuff
but i didn't realize it was like there's
elements of that that be that that
eventually come in you know to to play
with insecure but yeah i was a fan of
that and i just want to be part of the
world you know so you know just to be
included you know just to have my my
imdb or when the wikipedia you know tell
us they're just to have my name
definitely be in that universe
and so i lucked out in that
you know because i tested for the pilot
i tested for lawrence oh really oh yeah
i tested for lawrence and then i also
and then when the show got picked up i
came back and read for chad
um which became neil brown jr and then i
came back and read for
little rell's role uh the chicago lawyer
read for that i read for kendrick
sampson's uh part like i read for a lot
of then they just they just said that's
can we just put this fool on the show
yeah they just made the character that's
basically what happened and then when
they finally moved to the black law firm
and they came up with this character
they were like i think leonard should be
this guy and so oh you didn't even have
to audition or anything they just said
that well yeah
about you seven times before that yeah
what do you need to see more
you know y'all don't know what i could
do already in completely different roles
all of them yeah they sure are
but but when i came on in season three
it was it was no episodes guaranteed
there was any it wasn't even a lot of
description it was like black lawyer at
molly's new firm so at that point i just
kind of gambled
that
you know because oftentimes when we're
acting you know sometimes a role will
come by and your agents will get you to
you know they can gas you up a little
bit and like you above that you can pass
on that
and you know the if they like you that
much they'll find something better for
you right but you don't know what that
is until it shows up so yeah had i
passed on that it was like you know we
this is the thing you know something
better finally showed up
yeah i was like what are you passing for
you know you want me to
you know
it just lucked out i mean that season
season three i didn't have an episode
count but there's only eight
episodes in season three and i ended up
doing five of them oh yeah that's
practically
that's more than half of the episodes
now that it's it's a great show i i
really i've always enjoyed that show
i've talked about it on my podcast
before too i love that show
that's one of the few shows that's one
of
the
few modern shows where they um
show black women
like
as sexual
as vulnerable as like you know not some
stereotype of like what and even if
there is some stereotype they're showing
in such a real genuine way
you know what i mean and i just think
that's like a really great show for that
not even just black women just every
character and you know and then the city
you know and you know just the flow
how they show la too they show parts of
la they usually go i don't and they
don't even like
they don't even glorify
the ghetto part of it like they show
like even if it's like this is in the
ghetto but this is a great part of l.a
and they'll show it on a great day yeah
when people enjoy them yeah like how
people live in that area yeah that's
exactly it's the kind of thing that you
just don't see on tv as a person of
color you know what i mean it's like
it's always like you're being added to
some white show and then it's like and
then they have to like whatever the
message they're trying to send as
opposed to just a show that just it just
happens to star a lot of black people
yeah that's that's the only thing about
the show you know what i mean i just
anyways it is saying about a race thing
i'm just saying you know it's it's just
a very it's it's well done
for that reason you know i love it i
mean it really it really really really
grew on me and the other thing about the
shows are you know very progressive
about pushing the envelope
each season and changing things up for
themselves they never got really
comfortable and just doing one thing you
know there's an evolution to the you
know how even how the show was shot yeah
yeah and edited you know if you watch
every season everyone always know the
music is different you know all the
music i love
i mean uh like i was like i always think
they should get something for sound
editing every time just the way they the
cinematography with the music that they
play i don't always agree like there was
just one episode where
you know she's like giving the dude head
oh yeah that's that's a big that's one
of the big famous controversial episodes
like she gives she's given to do head
and then he like busts in her eye on her
face and she made like a big deal out of
that and i'm like
what
it's funny you knew the job was
dangerous when you took it
craig yeah you're not sucking what do
you think you're sucking on that's a
fire hose yeah yeah something's gonna
come out um craig and i were just
talking about that a couple weeks ago we
were both laughing about that episode
but
i asked him i was like he's like now
that's when i stopped watching the show
it just like just made them so mad why
did it oh because of like their their
their take on it just again yeah you
know what as a like as a man i didn't
appreciate how they were going at that
dude either like it's somehow like that
was somehow disrespectful but but
i will say this it's probably it was
probably
purpose very purposeful
because again the show was called
insecure yeah yeah yeah she's making a
choice just like to get a dude head like
that out of insecurity and then
she gets bust in her eye and it just
reinforces you know the idea like i
shouldn't have been doing it so then but
she can't own it
so she lashes out at him yeah and then
all the other girls jumped on right i
just wanted one of the girls to be like
i like that
that's all
you know what i'm saying that's the only
thing i didn't like i don't mind that
perspective i don't mind if like two or
three of them if her and the the main
the two main girls are like that's
ridiculous i can't i get that
perspective right but have one of those
girls be like oh i
i love it on my face
it probably would have been kelly yeah
right exactly i think it's the same
thing it'll be kelly i don't know i just
thought it was interesting and i don't
know and i know it was like on purpose
to to to have like to be this
controversial thing yeah because it's
like you know i know these this whole
hotel room is uncomfortable
that chair is the most uncomfortable
chair this couch is the most
uncomfortable couch the bed my back is
killing me i got to do my stretches
in the middle of the night i got to get
up and do stretches because everything
is so uncomfortable i mean it looks like
a nice hotel but i swear the sofa is
plastic
it's so ridiculous just there's no back
support nothing it's just like you know
but rachel would hate this couch because
you're you know you know but i don't
know but uh so what's what's on the
horizon man what's next for you well uh
yeah i mean that's the uh that's the
other thing about me i have so many
different things that i do and i'm
always juggling a bunch of different
things
uh you know of course always writing
trying to develop um some new television
to come on out for the for the new year
so hopefully i can pull that around and
then um and then yeah i mean you know
you saw me out this weekend reflexing my
stand-up muscles you know building that
back up it was good we had some great
shows out here too thank you arizona
thanks for all the people in arizona
that came out
yeah man maybe it's time for all maybe
it's time to collaborate you know and
get it all done you know
i think that uh you know people have
been real successful lately putting out
their own stuff and just putting
themselves out there and uh something
that i realized that i i have not done
a good job of is putting myself out
there into what do you think right away
what do you think that is
a lot of different reasons but i mean
you know the first one is is uh i'm very
protective of my work and whatever
because i'm a little bit of a
perfectionist yeah yeah but part of
being a perfectionist is like you know
it's it it's a little bit like you're
hiding a little bit you know
you know like it's good but since it's
not good enough just yet so you just
keep holding it out like what point do
you just go hey i gotta put this out
there but a lot of people i mean i think
a lot of what a lot of what makes people
successful is is a lot of failure
but you only get there by putting
yourself out there in the arena and you
might think it might not be bad but then
you know people might be like no i love
this and you're like oh then i'm on to
something then you can keep putting that
out there all right well let me ask you
this
do you think that it has to also do with
like because like we're guys you know in
our 40s
and it's like we came up in an era that
like tv and stuff was done a certain way
and do you think that we still hold on
to the idea that like oh no we can't do
this ourselves it's going to be yeah
we're going to be brought up by and you
know as opposed to like how i see like a
lot of young people that they're just
like you say like you're being an
influencer and creating things and it's
like
you know
yeah social media has like changed the
game for a lot of people you know
youtube
i think was the first big thing but but
social media has changed how people
perceive artists and entertainment and
what's good and who's talented and and
quality
i mean denzel denzel's never been a big
social media or paparazzi or anything
kind of guy he's always just been a guy
like focusing on the work just do the
work and i kind of gravitated to that
kind of mentality yeah yeah these are
people we don't know but the thing what
also too was those type of stars we
didn't know their life yeah we don't
know what was really going on yeah
because i'm sure denzel was a part of
producing and creating and doing other
stuff but we just didn't know we didn't
see it so we we assumed like it wasn't
possible or like there was some it was
like the keys to the castle that we
didn't know how to get there was
gatekeepers yeah you know this and it
seemed that there were more gatekeepers
before than there are now
yeah there are a lot of gatekeepers but
but to your you know i think really the
thing is if you're a craftsman like you
know like we think of ourselves as
craftsmen like i get into the the craft
the building of it the studying of it
the learning and making the stuff and
just taking my time and making something
really really great
but then then there's a then there's the
people who figure out how to mass
produce a bunch of stuff that looks
pretty good they know how to market and
sell it
so it's like if you want to buy a really
nice you know piece of furniture you got
to find a guy who makes furniture and
it's probably going to cost you more and
it's probably going to take time to get
it but if you want your apartment to
look nice and have a lot of furniture
like you can just go to ikea you know
well i think another example grabbing a
lot of stuff and it's it's what i'm
saying i think the example is of the
furniture maker is the thing yeah so
like if the furniture maker is like okay
i'm gonna make this great furniture and
the thing is like you go well how does
he get his
great furniture into ikea
yes you can think that but that guy that
most guys
if you're that guy that's like i'm
really in the front you don't want to be
in ikea you'd like people to i'm just
saying wherever it is you'd like me yeah
but you your specialties
you're saying well how does that guy
sell more furniture how does he instead
of sounding only a thousand a year how
does he get to sell a million and b but
not everybody should be that and not
everybody needs to be that well or
something don't you feel sometimes that
you feel like you do need to be that
when you're looking out at the landscape
well i mean maybe i mean it just just
depends on how you how you want your
life to shape up and what do you want to
be about i mean i i mean i'm sure you
and i both know people who seem to be
into this game for for the fame and not
really the yeah that what that's what
they do like they could do anything
sometimes it's stand up sometimes acting
somebody's right it's like it didn't
matter what lane they're just like what
would make me the most famous and make
me the most rich i was like so then
you're not really into this yeah you're
not really into the high highs or the
lows you just want to make sure you're
out front shining and it doesn't even
[ __ ] matter yeah and i think we also
like focus so much on the art form too
like yeah there's nothing wrong with
that something wrong but it's like there
is something that like when you focus
like oh if you had a pie you know
and like i think i come from an era
where the large part of the pie is about
being
the art form of being a stand-up let's
say you know what i mean and that's this
large part of that but now what we're
seeing is like that's a way smaller part
of the pie and the bigger part of the
pie is
you know
being a social media influencer you know
and all that kind of stuff to really get
yourself out there so then so you can
have somebody that's really great at
that but not as great at the stand-up
part and then and obviously it doesn't
really matter yeah but we we just like
look at it from the past being like well
this should matter and there's always
been something right the industry's
always been changing and flexing but and
i think there's always been these kind
of things like you know when the big
comedy boom of like the late 80s or i'm
sure there's a
probably a thousand comedians who like
got that late night set and we're
touring right now who don't do comedy
anymore because they're like oh this is
not my life this is not this is not what
i should be doing i ran out of material
years ago and whatever well i find a lot
of great writer producers some of the
greats they started and stand up tried
it failed at it and then moved on judd
apatow yep larry david you know just to
name two you know like they're just like
and they're like giants in the comedy
business
you know but they just like it just it
wasn't for them and some of them and
some of them started off and got some
fame and got some credit and and
notoriety and then got out of it you
know again to use larry david and judd
aptoide you know that was in what
hbo's young comedian specialist
yeah larry wilmore was a stand-up who's
done stuff you know
you know
the dude that created um um
entourage
him too oh right he was another guy that
was like he he was start he started to
do stand up and it was like
you know yeah some of them get get get a
little pop and then yeah they get into
some other stuff but you know i i just
think it's
the universe finds a way to figure it
out for you and uh for some people
luckily it happens
you know really fast
and maybe he can stick and then some
other people's like i'm on a journey i
feel like that's where i'm at well hey
i'm on this road yeah okay i enjoy these
stops whatever it is he stops and i'm
not always a hundred percent a stand-up
and and i have to accept that about
myself like i can't be as good as
somebody like in new york
grinding
stand up five sets a night every night
every night of the week i wish um i used
to that's how i started off but since i
got into la and got into more acting and
and more you know
uh writing opportunities and
and and acting opportunities i have to
accept that it's like i'm not just doing
one thing so i know but when you're and
it's crazy too though it's like when
you're like on a show especially when
you find yourself on a show
i mean stand-up suffers mm-hmm i mean it
just does yeah and the reason is is
because it's like you got a 6 a.m call
time where you got like and you just
can't be out late wow 10 10 14-hour days
we're learning lines and stuff and
trying to keep your energy a certain way
so i mean it just it does you know i i
always like oh damn i can't believe that
person is doing that or whatever
whatever it is you know but it's like i
don't know well if you had to choose
though what what would be the thing that
you know it's like gun to your head you
know writing acting stand up
yeah i i ask myself that question all
the time i was just like i i'ma run the
clock out on that one
i think my first passion in instinct and
desire was to be an actor and i only got
into those other things because i tried
and i started off trying to act and then
saw how all these other
writing or like improv or like stand up
could help yeah it could help my help
help my acting but i i have so much
pride and and respect for
all those things that i also just get
into that like that's funny because i
did i did improv and acting to help my
stand up
it's just weird how the different
perspectives you know well as i got into
him i was like oh i i need to master
this too yeah and then i need to master
this too yeah then it becomes a thing
where you just like you enjoy doing i
remember taking this
comedy
acting class it was this uh
it was like it was at ucla it was like
comedy acting and they had like a
showcase and and then i was trying to be
a stand-up at the time though but i
remember doing that and being like oh
like this is like a whole other
um artistic outlet that i really enjoy
as well yeah you know and then like you
know it's like just something about
taking somebody else's words and
bringing life to it you know or or
trying to like tap into an emotion or
whatever it is like that i mean i enjoy
i i enjoy that too and like for me like
when i was doing i'm dying up here i
enjoyed that even more because i was
like oh this isn't even like they're not
even asking me to be funny
you know and that was like one of these
things where i was like oh wow i'm
tapping into something like i just
happen to be funny in some of these
things but this is about this you know
this character and this like story and i
was like oh man yeah you when you start
learning you have different talents
within you it's like that becomes very
exciting and very interesting you're
like oh well yeah how far can i go with
this yeah so yeah so the message the
message there is just like get out there
guys you know stay out there stay on it
but i don't think i think anytime start
people start thinking about what am i
going to do that's going to make me more
famous or more popular like you're
starting off wrong
you know because that means you've just
immediately sold out any integrity or
originality that you have for yourself
you're just like i'm willing to do it
whatever it takes yeah that's why you
see so many not the [ __ ] on feet you
know female comics but there's there's a
bunch of female comics who are
probably very funny but i i don't know
based on your instagram because
you're coming up in the same feed as
like these instagram models who are
showing tits and ass all day trying to
you know get those numbers up and i was
like i skipped right over i'm like oh
wait this girl's a comedian oh it'd be
like if i made model cars
you know what i mean i'm really good at
making model cars and i just show myself
making model cars tonight at the comedy
store i'm making models you know
it had nothing to do with the
model dude there's nothing to do with it
but i'm like come see me you stand up
like the model car guy well i don't want
to see the motor car good yeah no but
but you know at the same time though i
go if that's in your wheelhouse if you
have that
ability to be
to to to grab people's attention because
of your looks then it is what it is i
mean i'm kind of doing it right now with
my instagram right now my instagram
pretty much just showcases me as an
actor like i'm not even really yeah
promoting or really featuring anything
like stuff so outfits and stuff so it's
the same kind of thing it's probably
confusing that people were like wait
wait that's some dude he's a stand-up
so that's what i'm saying so it's like i
don't know i mean i get what you're
saying though it's like sometimes i just
go i'll see like an advertisement for a
show for like one of these comics you're
talking about and i'll be like
what does this have to do with you being
funny yeah
you know and then it's like but then
there's others who like
um
can do it
and oh it just happened to be pretty no
you know it you know so i don't know
it's it's just like
this it feels like the wild wild west
right now also most men are pieces of
[ __ ] anyways we're all just like let me
see them titties one more time it's like
that's what i'm saying too though it's
like i wonder you know my question is
always like i wonder if it works what
like does it work like
have their guys have there been guys i
would love to ask some of these like
these comics to use their looks
i want to know like does a person come
to the show and be like man i came for
the team for the
[Laughter]
you got a fan now like i wonder like i
guess it must happen because if that if
it happens more frequently enough then
you go like i guess that worked
i heard i heard i heard her comic
talking about how she had a stalker at
the comedy store and i just thought
um that's got to be terrible to be
trying to be doing comedy right and then
you just got some you know male dudes
just like yeah but i'm not i'm not about
that comedy yeah it's like i'm a fan
it's like yeah i mean we guys are pieces
of [ __ ] we people want to [ __ ]
everything like i know
you put it that's what again that's what
i always have like i i understand i
remember when i first started i remember
i was doing comedy i'm doing triple runs
those montana shows
and then like the you know triple there
was this one female comic oh man i wish
i could remember her name but tribble
calls me and says hey man can you please
go with her like you guys do the because
you it'll be a two-man show okay once
you headline and have her because i'm
just she i want to
you know and i understood why
i understand why because
it's dangerous out there like we
literally were in montana driving
just driving from idaho to montana from
bozeman to butte from butte to you know
uh missoula you know and you know you're
like a woman you're out there on your
own you're you're just at some like
hotel bar it's not comedy clubs yeah and
you're just like there by yourself like
it's just like damn like how did like
it's like if i was somebody like that
and she was attractive too it'd be
something it'd be like why would i like
why would you want to go through that
like you want to pay your dues and you
want to go through the process of making
yourself better but then you have to
deal with men yeah i love it's like i
love comedy but i don't need to do that
yeah like yeah
at what point do you just go dan this
sucks
look i was just out there i can't
imagine doing driving all you know by
yourself period i was out there as a
black man like you know six months ago i
was like
all right when is friday coming because
i'm feeling a little worried
it was tough i remember doing those man
there were times where there was there
was times when you started to go to the
novelty of it wore off see this is what
we're talking about we circled back like
man the trouble runs that's one thing i
did not do but just that just makes
brings me back it makes me think it's
like not only how long you've been doing
it but the amount of stuff you did
to do it like the respecting that craft
and that hustle and you know that yeah
now i can see you know yes and that's
why i have a certain feeling about it
where i go man i really tried to hone my
skill in my craft and i had to do it
that way and so sometimes i do have like
there's a little bit of like there's a
little envy yes there's a little envy
when i see someone who like like even
like a good friend of mine like brendan
shop you know i'm gonna park i'm on
shout out to the king and sting people
but like brendan was like you know he's
a ufc fighter that is a big personality
and he's like you know he's got this
great personality and he was he got in
with like rogan and these people and
brian cowan and they were like yo man
why don't you try stand up so he was
able to do it that way so he he didn't
have to do this stuff that i had to do
you know and it's just like you go well
good
because maybe if i had that opportunity
we didn't have those opportunities yeah
you know so it's like so we say that's
the way you had to do it because it was
the only way to do it there was no
internet there was no social media yeah
so it's like these people that are doing
it now that's like so for him
you know being an influencer and being
that that was his triple runs yeah it's
like i wonder you know like if like if
it's
it's almost like not everybody should
have to suffer or needs to suffer
necessarily get good or to succeed yeah
it's like but though to those who have
suffered just like
get yourself get your soft ass out there
get your sufferer on get your suffer on
get you know get you get punched in the
eye once or twice so i can call you a
man please but maybe their suffering is
that process that they were doing before
that yeah you know you know so it's it
and i think it's just like you just have
this sort of like
feeling about it you know as
you know
as as someone that came up differently
and now you see the way it is now you
just kind of go oh man so it's like
either get with the times yeah or like
you know it's like shut up and move on
mean you know i don't know but a lot of
people do move on we talk about like hey
whatever happened to yeah you know and
these guys are just gone yeah they're
just gone because this business will eat
you up that's what i say like you know
to the whole thing like i don't care you
know hey look if you just step out on
the scene and blow up and it works for
you or if you got to grind it out for a
long time like it i don't think it
matters like the universe has a way of
yeah fixing it all for everybody for you
know what's right for them and you
shouldn't be worried about who's on to
your left or to your right you know
everybody's got their own path
and
i don't know because maybe maybe
somebody was looking at me when i came
to l.a and was like who the hell's this
dude six months in l.a all the sudden
wild and out right right but you know
they're not privy to like oh well i was
in new york doing improv
everybody has like like they they
respect
the journey a different way or they
disrespect the journey yeah 100 and then
and then while i was doing this i was
like i was also still taking class like
i was like yeah i'm doing it improvingly
i'm also still taking improv classes
actively
still taking acting classes
they take they try to take it away from
you that's just people it's the nature
of it yeah you know so again you look at
the female comics they
we try to take it away from them by
saying like well you know you're only
getting that because you're pretty or
whatever and so
taking away their journey you know and
so i don't know getting deep on griffin
today getting deep riffing on griffin
well listen we this is a good amount of
time i think we've done it
um just love editing this mess i don't
think there's no editing i just oh you
just dump it yeah oh then i'm sorry i
called this a mess
are you sorry piece of [ __ ]
but i'll have leonard's information on
the episode you can find him i am
leonard robinson on instagram most
things on instagram and you check him
out if you you can catch up on insecure
on hbo max the actually today is sunday
so
it's a serious finale today or is it
next week next week hot episode drop
tonight though yeah yeah he had a good
episode tonight i'm catching up on it
you know because i like
sometimes with that show i like to let
it build up because i hate when i'm like
oh what's next what's next and then you
have to let you know what i mean save
yourself a bit yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so i love it but he checked him out on
insecure on hbo
and uh doing stand-up he's around all
the time he's also at the groundlings if
you're in the la area you want to go
watch an improv you're having sketch at
the groundlings theater
scratch yeah home club at the is a
comedy store in l.a with eric yeah so we
doing that all the time and i might and
i might bring leonard again on some
other trip that i go on and so you might
see us out there together so make sure
you look out for that catch me daily on
twitch eric griffin gaming
um
and
yeah i hope you enjoyed the ghostbusters
sort of like review and then i'm gonna
do a spiderman review next week that
movie was so good so i want to talk
about it so i don't want to spoil so you
have a week to watch it if you watch me
with griffin you have a week to get out
of watching because i will be spoiling
it next week
i feel so ashamed you should feel the
shame you need to go see it
we almost watched it after ghostbusters
just because
just to cleanse the palette yeah we
needed
the ginger
but this has been riffing with griffin
thanks again to linda robinson thanks
for being here my friend and i will see
you next week peace